What if you could hear what I'm saying by
measuring the vibrations of the stuff on the
wall behind me?
Well, now you can.
Howdy spygamers, Trace here for DNews, so
LISTEN UP!
Science fiction has long talked about high-tech
eavesdropping equipment that can extract sound
from the environment; like by measuring vibrations
in the windows or coffee mugs.
When a guitar string is plucked, the string
wooshes through the air passing its energy
to the air molecules it comes in contact with.
Those molecules hit other molecules and pass
that energy on in waves, to more molecules
and so on, all the way to your ears.
All those vibrating molecules are ALSO hitting
walls, your clothing, your hair, a bag of
chips… everything in the room!
They keep going until the energy from that
guitar string is dissipated.
Those vibrations are invisible to the naked
eye, but not to cameras.
A new paper from researchers at MIT looks
at how to extract sound information from those
vibrations.
The researchers call this new technology,
The Visual Microphone.
They use a high speed video camera to measure
the sound vibration of things like chip bags,
plant leaves... anything exposed to those
extraneous sound vibrations.
It takes those vibrations, converts them into
sound waves which can be played back.
The genius part of their technology is the
ability to catch vibrations at a higher rate
than even the camera can see.
A good consumer-grade camera might only shoot
60 frames each second, but if the vibration
is around 5,000 hertz,[a] or cycles per second,
the camera can't see it.
It's happening too fast!
So, to get around that, these researchers
looked at HOW the camera captures 60 frames…
it's digital, so it does it one line at a
time.
For HD video, that could mean 1080 lines per
frame.
Minute changes in how the chip bag vibrates
in between those lines reveal the whole range
of human hearing, from 20 hertz to 20,000
hertz.
Eavesdropping technology has come a long way.
Imagine robots that can sense your emotions
from the way blood is pumping through your
skin, and tiny movements of your muscles in
super high resolution at thousands of frames
per second -- AND they could even hear you
by looking at a vibrating plant in the room.
We're screwed.
Stuff like this has been used in science fiction
before, and obviously has immediate implications
for intelligence-gathering operations.
But the researchers ALSO believe this could
be used to explore the STRUCTURES of the things
they're using to measure vibration.
Which could be interesting, though I'm not
sure what that could do… and sometimes,
that's where the best science comes from.
What is the ultimate eavesdropping technology?
Bugs are still the most reliable, but what
would be the BEST?
Share your spy dreams with us and be sure
you subscribe for more DNews.
We release new videos twice a day!
I'm Trace, thanks for watching.